As I mentioned last class, there are
three major questions that will
determine how this war is fought, what
the what this war
will end up looking like, and how the
world will change.
And as I discussed last class, I'm
making three predictions about this war.
The first is United States will use
ground troops.
And this will mean that
Donald Trump will institute a national
draft. Okay? That's the first
prediction. Second prediction is that
Israel and the United States will not
use tactical nuclear weapons in this
war.
Number three is that the Al-Aqsa Mosque,
the third holiest site in the Islamic
world, will be destroyed during this
war.
Okay, so last class, I explained my
analysis and my reasoning for
my first two predictions. Today, I'll
explain my
third prediction. So, but before we
start, I just want to look at some
videos, okay? So, you understand some of
the context, some of the players in this
war. All right, so this is Senator
Blumenthal of Connecticut, and he is one
of the 100 members of the US Senate.
He's also one
of the members of the Gang of Eight.
Now,
when when you are fighting a war,
the White House has responsibility to
report its
objectives, its purpose,
how the war is progressing to eight
members
of Congress in a confidential setting,
okay? And this is um
Senator Blumenthal after he's been
debriefed by
the White House. Okay, and this is what
he has to say about the progress of the
war so far.
I emerge from this briefing
as dissatisfied
and angry, frankly,
as I have from any
past briefing
in my 15 years in the Senate.
I am
left with more questions than answers,
especially about the cost of the war.
My questions [snorts]
have been unanswered.
And I will demand answers because the
American people deserve to know.
And
I guess I am most
concerned about the threat to American
lives
of potentially deploying our sons and
daughters on the ground in Iran. We seem
to be on a path
toward deploying American troops on the
ground in Iran
to accomplish any of the potential
objectives here.
And
there is also
as disturbingly as anything else, this
factor of active Russian aid to Iran
putting in danger
American lives.
All right.
So, three things to take away from
his talk with reporters, okay? The first
thing is
>> [snorts]
>> the administration, Donald Trump, the
White House, has not articulated a
budget. How much will this war cost?
Which means that this is an open-ended
war. We don't know when this war will
end.
And so, we don't know what the
commitment is, and so we don't know how
much this war will cost, okay? That's
the first point he makes. The second
point he makes is we are on a path
towards the deployment of ground troops
in Iran.
Okay, and that basically means a
national draft. Now, the third thing
that's crucial is he says that they know
for a fact that Russia is already
involved
in this war aiding Iran.
Okay? So, that's the three main
takeaways
from
um
Okay, so this is um
um the foreign minister of Iran, Zarif,
talking to NBC News. All right. And NBC
News is going to ask Zarif, "Hey,
there's talk United States already of
ground troops being used against
uh Iran, okay?" Now, I want you to
observe his response and then the
response of the journalist.
President Trump has not ruled out boots
on the ground in Iran. Are you afraid of
a [snorts] US invasion in your country?
No, we are waiting for them.
You you were waiting for the US military
to invade, the ground troops?
Yes.
Because [clears throat] we we are
confident that we can confront them, and
that would be a big disaster for them.
Okay, do you understand? Okay.
So, you're saying that that Iran is
ready and willing to take on the US
military if there were to be ground
troops?
Well, we were ready for this. Okay, so
again, certain things to appreciate.
First of all, the foreign minister,
Zarif, he is not at all concerned about
ground troops. In fact, he basically
said, "It's a trap for you guys. You
come in, we've been preparing for about
20 years for this, we will destroy you."
Another thing that you will notice is
the journalist is completely surprised
by the answer. He's shocked into
silence. He has asked again, "Wait, are
you saying you're ready for ground
troops?"
And so, this shows you that within
Washington, D.C., okay, within
the Trump administration, within the
foreign policy elite, within the media
elite, they haven't really thought this
through. They haven't really
considered the possibility
of losing this war. Washington, D.C.
right now, it's a bubble, okay? It's an
insular bubble where everyone just
believes the same things, and that's
very problematic um if you are to
continue fighting this war, okay?
>> [snorts]
>> All right, let's continue.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay,
this is um
um
Rabbi Schneerson.
And he is the leader, or he used to be
he he's died, but he used to be the
leader of an organization called the
Chabad Lubavitch. I'll be talking more
about Chabad Lubavitch as we go along,
okay? But I introduce you to him now.
This is the year 1990, and he is talking
to Benjamin Netanyahu, who is who is a
young up-and-coming
politician in Israel, okay? And so,
let's look at the conversation.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay, so what's going on here? Okay, so
as an up-and-coming politician,
Netanyahu is going to a rabbi, and the
rabbis are the most powerful people in
the Jewish society. He basically says,
"Will you give me your blessing? Will
you support me in my political
endeavors?" The rabbi says, "Yes." They
also talk about how things are
progressing, okay? So, another way of
saying this is that there's almost like
a plan in motion to achieve certain
religious objectives, and things are
going well. But the
Rabbi Schneerson says,
"But they're not going fast enough,
because we need the Messiah,
the great leader of the Jewish people,
to come, and we can set in motion things
that will force the coming of the
Messiah. So, let's speed things up,
Netanyahu."
Okay? So, what this is, I'll explain
later on, okay? But I want you to be
aware of this, who these people are.
Rabbi Schneerson is very important for
our story, and Netanyahu, of course, is
the current prime minister of Israel.
All right, let's continue.
All right.
We want to know what you're reading now.
What I'm reading? Yeah. The Jews against
Rome. What made you pick it up?
Well, we lost that. That's why I think
we have to win the next one.
We want to know what you're reading now.
Okay.
All right, so that's a very quick
exchange, okay? So, a journalist is
asking
Benjamin Netanyahu, "What book are you
reading now?" And he says, "Jews versus
Sorry, Rome versus the Jews." It's a
book by Barry Strauss, an historian. And
it goes about goes on about the three
wars that the Jews fought against the
Romans. And it was essentially a
holocaust for the Jews. A lot of Jews
either died or were enslaved. The Romans
burned down the second temple. So, this
is historical animosity of the Jews
against the Romans, okay? But what you
But But what he said is what What
Benjamin Netanyahu said is that "I'm
reading this book because we lost that
war against Rome. But the next war
against Rome, we must not lose." The
question then is who's Rome?
It's not Iran, guys. It's probably not
Russia. It's probably America, right?
The great empire.
So, this is strange because Israel is
the ally of America in this war. But
Netanyahu is saying that
"No, our real enemy is Rome. And that's
what we must prepare for." Okay? So, I
want you guys to keep this in mind.
All right. This is Peter Hoekstra, who
is a secretary of war for
Donald Trump, okay? And this is the year
about 2018,
where he is in Jerusalem, and he's
talking
to Christian Zionists and Zionists,
okay? Who these people are, I'll explain
later on, okay? But let's let's listen
to his speech really quickly.
And I know had a chance to go see the
Western Wall of the Temple Mount, the
Western Wall tunnels,
so much of the old city. And as you
stand there, you can't help but behold
the miracle before you.
And it got me thinking about another
miracle that I hope all of you don't see
too far away. Because 1917 was a
miracle.
1948 was a miracle. 1967 was a miracle.
2017, the declaration of Jerusalem as
the capital, was a miracle. And there's
no reason why the miracle of the
reestablishment of the temple on the
Temple Mount is not possible.
Okay. So, he is a Christian. He's not a
Jew.
But what he's saying is that he's come
to Jerusalem and he's visited these
Jewish holy sites.
And he can't be He can't help be
be amazed, be awed by the beauty,
the spirituality of the Western Wall. He
also goes on to say that the There's
been a series of miracles, okay? So,
1917 was the Balfour Declaration, when
basically the British Empire permitted
the Jews to found the nation-state of
Israel. 1948 was when Israel was
founded. 1967 was when the the when
Israel fought a war against its Arab
neighbors and won.
Okay? And 2017
was when Donald Trump transferred
American Embassy from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem, thus recognizing Jerusalem as
the capital of Israel. And what he's
saying is that "Well, if this is a
series of steps to achieving the divine
plan, then the next miracle should be
the rebuilding of Solomon's Temple, the
third temple.
And that means destroying the Al-Aqsa
Mosque.
Okay?
So, what's going on here? Okay, again,
I'll explain to you later on, but I want
I want you to be aware of who these
people are and how they think. All
right, let's go one more video. And so,
if you want to build Solomon's Temple,
if you want to build the third temple,
you need to get rid of the third holiest
site
in the Islamic world. And how do you do
that?
Well, there are some options, okay? So,
missiles will hit the mosque
and clear the place for the third Bet
Hamikdash.
That could also be a a miracle if
If it was up to me, the last time when
they shot hundreds of missiles, I would
pretend that one missile came from Iran
and shoot it down.
You know,
then all the Arabs will go against Iran,
that will be the end of the problems.
You make them fight with each other,
this bunch of lunatics.
Never too late to deal with a bunch of
cowards.
Okay? So, this is a rabbi in Israel.
He's saying how last year, during the
12-day war in June,
Iran was firing missiles
at Israel. And what he's saying is, "You
know, that was an opportunity for us to
pretend
that an Iranian missile hit the Dome of
the Rock, the Al-Aqsa Mosque, thus
destroying it.
And then well, the Arabs will blame the
Iranians, and the Arabs will go to war
against the Persians. And then we can
just sit back and laugh at these
lunatics."
Okay?
So, again, this may be confusing to you
as to who these people are, why they are
saying these things.
All right? But now what what I'm going
to do is explain to you what is really
going on, okay? And I keep on saying
this, but it is hard from a from a
geopolitical perspective to explain this
US-Iran war. You have to look at the
religious perspective, okay? The
religious angle. And that's what I want
to focus on today.
Okay.
Sorry.
Okay. So, again,
this is
the three holiest site
in the Islamic world.
Um this is Saudi Arabia, Mecca, Medina,
and this is
the
Dome of the Rock, the Al-Aqsa Mosque,
which is where Muhammad was supposed to
ascend to heaven.
And the Jews and the Christian Zionists
believe that this must be destroyed so
that they can build the third temple, or
Solomon's Temple, okay?
>> [snorts]
>> All right. So, this is the big question
in this war. And again, I I hate I I
keep on saying this, but I need to be
right if my prediction, if my analysis
is to be correct. If they do not destroy
the Al-Aqsa Mosque, and if they are able
to achieve peace,
then my predictive model, my analysis is
is completely wrong. You can just ignore
me, okay? For the rest of my life. I
I can I can go back to teaching, you
know, the great books or something. All
right.
So, let us examine
w-
um
why this is important, okay? So, today I
want to introduce you to a new theory of
game theory called the law of
eschatological convergence.
Okay.
So, this is a very hard thing to write
down, okay? It sounds complicated, but
it's not, okay? Eschatology,
what it is is a story
of how the world ends.
And it's very comp-
And it's it's it's very
compelling for people because, remember,
we discussed this last semester, but as
human beings, we have three questions.
Where do we come from?
Why are we here? Where are we going?
And eschatology
provides a story that answers all three
questions. Why God created us, what our
mission on Earth is, and what God has
planned for the end of the world, okay?
And different traditions will have
different eschatologies.
And what's important to figure out is
in what aspect
do these eschatologies converge, okay?
Converge, meaning a union
of these eschatologies.
And why is that important? Because it
allows you to predict how they will
behave.
Think of a story as the operating system
of a society.
And as such, it's a script that they
will act out.
And if you're able to figure out
the different scripts and see how they
converge together, where the union of
these different scripts are, then you
can actually predict how the world will
turn out.
Okay? All right. So, having explained
the law,
I'm going to some theory to help us
understand
why this is why this works, okay? All
right. So, the first thing to understand
is something called
the universal
law of game theory.
Okay? And the universal law of game
theory states this.
Whoever wins a game
is able to do this, okay? Mass
times
um energy
coordination.
Okay? So, these are the three things you
want to look at
to understand how well player would do
in a game. So, mass is just the number
number of people involved
um on the team, okay?
Energy is just how much attention,
focus, motivation there is, okay? So,
think of think of it as attention
or motivation
or action, okay? Any of these words will
do. But, basically, how how invested are
you in winning the game?
And how willing how hard you willing to
work to win the game? And in
coordination, it's just the idea of
synchronicity.
And what I mean by that is
how well
do
the teammates work together?
Okay?
And something that you need to
appreciate is that the most important
thing in what in winning a game is
actually coordination. In fact, I would
say it's four times more important than
just mass. So, you could have a lot of
people but if they don't work well
together, you're defeated by another
team with few few people, but they work
well together, okay?
And then energy is twice as important as
mass.
All right. So, let me give you an
example. Let's just say that you're
playing a game by yourself.
Okay? May maybe maybe for example, you
enter a ping pong competition or a chess
competition. Well, mass and coordination
don't really matter cuz you don't have
any teammates.
And so, what matters is energy. How
motivated you are to win this game. How
much time do you put in practice? How
much time do you put into studying and
improving yourself? How much how focused
are you in winning, okay?
All right. So, a team sport uh well,
mass is constant, and so what matters is
energy and coordination.
How well the team works
uh well together, okay? Now,
um what's interesting is that there are
different ways to
improve or increase automatically the
energy and coordination. All right? So,
maybe
um
a leader.
Okay? So, maybe if someone is a really
inspiring leader, that will make people
much more motivated. That will allow
them to work well together cuz all they
have to do is listen to a leader.
Okay?
The problem with leader, of course, is
that eventually he will die.
All right? Then you have a family, okay?
Blood.
Okay?
Um they work well together because they
all share similar blood.
But, we cannot account for the
differences within this family, okay?
The conflict within this family, right?
So, historically, in a long term, um the
force that allows teams to beat other
teams is the idea of narrative.
Okay? Narrative.
Or a story.
Okay? Why? Because it implants in the
minds of all those who believe in the
narrative
a series of actions that they must take
in order to win the game, okay? So,
think of it as a script. And in a in a
script, you know what part you play, so
you just have to act it out. And that
allows for you all to work together to
achieve the outcome that you desire,
okay?
Does that make sense? Okay? And in
narrative, the most powerful powerful
uh form of narrative is the idea of
eschatology.
Because eschatology is a complete
script.
A complete script in which everyone
knows
what he or she must do in order to
achieve the desired outcome. And
eschatology also is able to transcend
both time and space.
Meaning that
um you can actually spend centuries
acting out the script because everyone
knows his role anyway, okay?
And it can transcend borders, as well.
You can you can go beyond ethnic
identity and family, okay? So, the most
powerful mechanism in history is
eschatology.
All right? So,
what is eschatology?
All right. So,
most religions
are similar.
Most religions require you to be a good
person, be humble, be kind, be generous.
But, there are certain aspects of
religions that are extreme, okay? We can
we can call them eschatologies.
Okay? So,
the classic example is the Jewish
religion, okay? In the Jewish religion,
if you're
um
what you believe is that you you you no
longer live in Israel because a long
time ago, the Israelites pissed off God
by disobeying him. God told the
Israelites, "Do not worship false
idols." But, the Israelites sinned, they
disobeyed, so they were kicked out of
Jerusalem, and they were forced to
wander the earth in the diaspora for
centuries. And so, what they believe is
that they each need to engage in an act
of redemption, of humility,
of submission, of piety to God if they
are to redeem the whole Jewish people,
okay? And when that happens, when they
recognize their own limitations, when
they recognize
um how inferior they are to God and
submit to God, then God will send the
Messiah
to redeem them and lead them back to
Jerusalem,
defeat the enemies of the Jews,
bring all the Jews from the diaspora
back to Jerusalem, unify the Jewish
people, and then build the third temple
so that God can come to earth and live
with all the Jews and create heaven on
earth, okay?
That is the um
Jewish religion
that most Jews believe. Okay, like there
are a lot of differences, okay? But but
I'm just trying to simplify it for
clarity, okay?
But, then you have these extremes,
fanatics,
who have a different
eschatology, okay? And these people we
can say are accelerationists.
And what And their point is that
this is fine, but it's way too slow.
And it dissolves us of individual
responsibility. If you have faith in
God, then you should want to hurry
things up and um force the return of God
as soon as possible. And you do that by
recognizing that
um
if you
actually, before the Messiah comes, if
you actually go and create the nation of
Israel, bring all the Jews back, build
the third temple, defeat all the
enemies, then the Messiah will come
naturally,
okay?
And so, of course, most Jews hear this
and they think that this is blasphemy,
it's heresy.
Because you are defying the will of God.
You think you can manipulate God into
action. That is wrong.
That is the opposite of redemption. That
is the worst possible sin you can make,
okay? And so,
this eschatology
is considered a fringe, an extreme,
something to be ignored. The problem,
though, is that if you think about it,
what an eschatology really is doing is
creating a vector
to force a religion to move in a certain
direction,
okay?
And also, if you think about it, if this
is the case where eschatology is a
vector that forces the mainstream to
move in a certain direction,
then whichever eschatology is the most
extreme, the most violent,
will be the one that wins out,
okay?
Okay, does that make sense? In other
words, what we're going to do today is
look at the most extreme versions of
different eschatologies
because, quite honestly, even though
these extreme versions are shared by
only a few people,
they're the ones who are working the
hardest
to achieve their eschatology, and
therefore, they're forcing the religion
they are in to move a certain way.
Okay?
All right.
So,
um you hear this and and you think this
is all confusing, but what I what I'll
do now is I'm going to share with you
a passage from a biography of Rabbi
Schneerson. Remember, we um
we had a look at Rabbi Schneerson
talking to Netanyahu and saying, "Hurry
up. Let's hurry up the the return of
Messiah." Okay?
Um he is
uh in charge of
Chabad Lubavitch,
>> [snorts]
>> which again
is
an extreme eschatology. But again,
because they are so extreme, they're
willing they're willing to work as hard
as possible to achieve their vision, and
therefore they are forcing the Jewish
mainstream in a certain direction.
Okay?
All right. So, um this is a biography of
Rabbi
Schneerson.
And the Chabad Lubavitch movement um was
founded in modern-day uh Belarus.
And [clears throat]
over time, it went over to America
because they suffered a lot of
persecution
um by the Russians.
And today, they are global movement. And
they are powerful in Russia, in America,
and in Israel.
Okay? So, we will discuss the Chabad
Lubavitch as we move along, but I want
to with this passage show you
how coordination
among eschatologists work, okay? All
right. So, so the year is 1939.
And the Nazis Nazi Germany's again who
are anti-Semitic, they hate Jews.
They want all Jews out of Europe. They
are overrunning Europe. And by 1939,
they have conquered Poland,
Warsaw.
Okay? Now, Poland Warsaw is where the
head rabbi, the rebbe, of the Chabad
Lubavitch movement is. And his name is
um
Yosef Yitzchak, okay? And he's the
father-in-law of Rabbi Schneerson.
And [snorts] he's an old man, and he's
in Warsaw. The Nazis are overrunning the
city. So, his followers in America
are
are want to save his life, okay?
So, the then the question is like, "But
how do you do that?" Because America and
Germany are not best friends. The war is
breaking out in
um
Europe, and
Yosef Yitz- Yitzchak is a very old man.
And there are no plane Well, there are
planes, but there are no commercial air
flights that you can take, okay?
So, it's going to be a very long,
arduous journey across many borders.
Plus, um
he will need a visa, not just for
himself, but for his whole family.
Okay?
Now, what I will show you is how
powerful these people are. And again,
this is an eschatology where they all
share similar vision, and therefore
they're willing to make the necessary
sacrifices in order to help each other
achieve this vision, okay? All right.
So, this is from the biography.
An ocean away in America, Yosef
Yitzchak's followers were mounting a
rescue effort. With the help of Sam
Kramer, an Orthodox attorney and son of
Lubavitcher immigrants, the Chabad
activist Israel Jacobson hired Max
Rhoade, a politically connected lawyer,
to secure American visas for Yosef
Yitzchak and his family, okay? So, in
other words, even though there there may
may not be that many followers, they
have a wide
um political circle. And a lot of reason
why is that um they pool their resources
together. And when they pool their
resources together, they're able to
invest in real estate together, they're
able to invest in business together, and
they're able to generate a lot of money,
which they can then which they can then
use influence politics in America, okay?
They can buy politicians, they can um do
a lot of things.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay. So, the first part is easy,
getting visas for
uh the rabbi and his family.
Now, the problem is how do you actually
get to him, okay? Cuz there are no
telephones, there's no internet, there
are no airplanes. How do you find him in
when there's a war going on in Poland
when there are Nazis everywhere, okay?
All right, let's continue.
Yosef uh Yitzchak's followers also
reached out to Attorney General Benjamin
Cohen, okay? And Supreme Court Justice
Louis Brandeis, okay? This guy This man
is very important. He's what I call a
Shabbatean Frankist.
What I will show you later on is that
uh Shabbatean Frankists and the Chabad
Lubavitch movement are very much allied,
okay? So, even though they're not part
of the same movement, they are
sympathetic towards each other. And he's
the most powerful Jew in America at this
time, okay? In the in the 1930s, '40s.
Um whom Yosef Yitzchak had met during
his fundraising trip of 1929. The
Lubavitch efforts in America were
successful, all right? So, they won over
the Americans. They They won over the
entire American political apparatus, and
they are dedicated to helping
the rabbi escape Europe and come to
America.
All right. Now, the second part is how
do you deal with the Nazis?
Okay.
The Lubavitch efforts in America were
successful. On October 2nd, Cohen wrote
to Robert Pell, a senior official in the
State Department, asking for help. The
next day, Pell contacted Hellmuth
Wohlthat, a German and a member of the
Nazi Party, a Nazi, who specialized in
national industry and economics to see
if he would be willing to save one of
the leading Jewish scholars in the
world, okay? This is a guy, American,
writing to a Nazi and saying, "Hey, man,
uh I know you're a Nazi, but we need
your help to save a Jew."
And the guy says, "Yes."
Okay?
Um Wohlthat was strategically chosen. He
had studied at Columbia University in
the early 1930s and had forged a
relationship with Pell after the Evian
Conference on Jewish refugees in 1938.
Um seeing an opportunity to curry
goodwill with the United States,
Wohlthat secretly contacted Admiral
Wilhelm Canaris, the head of German
military intelligence. Wow.
The head of German military intelligence
is saying, "Hey, man,
let's help this guy."
Canaris, a skeptical Nazi who
disapproved of SS atrocities and thought
the invasion of Poland a mistake,
enlisted Major Ernst Bloch, a
distinguished veteran of
World War I and one of the most trusted
officers. Bloch was a Mischling, okay? A
Mischling just means a German who had
some Jewish ancestry, but because he was
so valorous in World War I, he was
considered a German, okay?
Um he had been declared of German blood
by Hitler in 1939. Along with three
other soldiers, two of whom were also
Mischling, Bloch was instructed to find
Yosef Yitzchak and bring him to safety.
Wow.
The Nazis, okay?
despatched their own soldiers to find
this guy and bring him to America. And
this is again during war.
>> [snorts]
>> But how do you find this guy? Bloch and
his colleagues had to maneuver through
the ruins of Warsaw without suspicions
of the SS to find a rabbi who did not
know of their mission and did not want
to be found, okay? So, this rabbi is
hiding from everyone. So, how do you
find this guy?
And he's deadly afraid of all German
soldiers because he sees them as just
Nazis.
There's another problem.
Well, Jews in the city were naturally
unwilling to divulge the location of a
Hasidic leader to a Nazi officer.
Eventually, information came from the
Americans. Brandeis was informed of
Yosef Yitzchak's address by the Chabad
lawyer Arthur Rubinowitz and relayed it
via Cohen and Pell to the US chargé
d'affaires in Germany. This requires the
coordination of dozens and dozens of
people who are supposed to be on the
opposite side of a war. And they're
working together to achieve a goal.
>> [snorts]
>> Um at the end of November, Bloch found
Yosef Yitzchak's apartment and after
some confusion convinced the residents
he was there to help. Once he had
obtained fuel coupons, train tickets,
and military clearances for SS
checkpoints, Bloch loaded Yosef Yitzchak
and his family onto a truck and headed
for the train station. There, the family
received first-class tickets and boarded
a train filled with Nazi officials and
soldiers.
Okay? And that's how they got out.
In other words, they are able to work
above the bureaucracy of different
nation-states
in order to achieve their eschatological
goal, okay?
All right.
Does that make sense?
So, now what I'm going to do is
I'm going to go into the idea of
eschatological convergence.
Because once we know the different
eschatologies, and we know how they
converge together, we can actually make
certain predictions about how this war
will progress. Okay. So, the first major
eschatology I I want to look at is
called Zoroastrianism. And this is the
first
eschatology.
And the it's a it's a it's a it's a
eschatology of the Persian Empire, okay?
And this eschatology is very simple.
In the world, there's truth and the lie,
okay? The light and the darkness. And it
it is our responsibility as humans to
live for the light, to die for the truth
against the lie. And at the end of days,
there will be a final battle and a day
of judgment, okay? So, light
versus dark,
and then you have a day of judgment.
Okay? Where the god Ahura Mazda will
come down, and he will create a paradise
for everyone. Okay? So, what matters is
to live a noble life and await the day
of judgement where eventually
heaven on earth will manifest, okay?
>> [snorts]
>> And this is important because if you
think about how the Iranians are
fighting this war, the Iranians refuse
to take the initiative and destroy too
much, okay? They refuse to be the
villains in this war because for them,
in their eschatology, it's important to
die for the light, to fight for the
truth, okay?
Now, Jewish eschatology has a major
impact on
Jewish eschatology, okay? And Jewish
eschatology, again,
I'm only talking about the most extreme
version of this eschatology, okay? And
in this eschatology,
the idea is that the Jews
disobeyed God, okay? Disobedience.
>> [snorts]
>> And what And in order to repair the
world, to save themselves, to create
heaven on earth, they need to engage in
redemption, okay? Redemption.
And redemption is really about spiritual
alchemy, improving yourself as a person,
being good to yourself, being good to
others, loving your neighbor as though
you would love yourself, okay? That's a
mainstream idea.
But in an In the most extreme version,
redemption just means acting out God's
plan to
compel the return of the Messiah, okay?
And this plan is basically
create Israel,
>> [snorts]
>> return
Jewish diaspora,
build the third temple.
And this will lead them to call the war
of Gog and Magog.
And then, when the Jews
are most threatened, the Messiah will
come to save them
from their enemies. And this will create
something called the Messianic age,
okay? When God rules over the earth
through his Messiah, who comes from the
house of David.
Okay. All right. So, again, this is a
simple version. There are lots of
different versions. This is the most
simple version for our purposes, okay?
Now, what's interesting is that this
Jewish eschatology would go on to
influence the Protestants,
okay? And this creates a movement called
Christian Zionism.
Christian Zionism,
so the technical word for Christian
Zionism is called premillennial
dispensationalism.
Okay? And this sounds very complicated,
but it's not. What means is that
God has a plan
for how to create heaven on earth, and
we have a duty to fulfill his plan by
following his instructions,
okay? All right. So, what Christian
Zionism is doing is that it takes this
Jewish eschatology and makes certain
changes to it, okay? So, for example,
the first change that it makes is, okay,
this plan is fine, but rather than say
that the Jewish Messiah is the
representative of God, what they say is
that, no, he's actually the
representative of Satan, okay? So, the
Messiah
in the Jewish tradition becomes the
Antichrist
in the Christian Zionist tradition. And
why is this important? It's important
because for the Christians, the Messiah
must be Jesus, okay? So, the Messiah So,
the Antichrist, what he does is that he
rules over the world. He's very
charismatic and he rules the world in
Jerusalem. And he starts the war of Gog
war of Gog and Magog
in order to conquer the world and
destroy the Jews. At this At this point,
Jesus will return to save God's chosen
people, the Jews.
And
when Jesus returns, there will be
something called the rapture, where all
Christians will immediately ascend to
heaven, okay? So, the rapture.
All right, okay? So, again, Christian
Zionism is working off Jewish
eschatology,
but it's making some important changes,
okay?
So, another thing this is,
in the beginning, Zionists and Christian
Zionists will work together to reach a
certain point of history,
okay? What we call the Great Racial
Project.
But then they will diverge and fight
against each other, okay?
So, they're allies now, but eventually
they'll turn against each other.
All right. So, now I'm going to talk
about the Freemasons
because the Freemasons
We'll talk about the Freemasons later,
okay? The Freemasons are also working
within the Christian Zionist context.
>> [snorts]
>> But they are much more focused on
actually how to implement this, okay?
So, what they want to do is they want to
take the Antichrist
and turn it into a system.
And this system we discussed last
semester is called Pax Judaica.
What is Pax Judaica? Pax Judaica is that
Israel controls the world through AI,
okay? An AI surveillance state.
Okay?
Or their exact words is holy empire.
And Pax Judaica, the AI surveillance
state, wants things such as the mark of
the beast.
And what is the mark of the beast?
It is digital ID.
Okay? And this digital ID will also lead
to digital currency. And they can
actually put a microchip or a QR bar in
your forehead, and this will be
considered the mark of the beast, okay?
And it's all part of the Christian
Zionist eschatology.
Another really important thing about the
Freemasons is the idea of a one world
government
because, remember, the Antichrist is the
leader of the one world government.
And it will be based in Jerusalem, okay?
And so, the headquarters will be
Solomon's Temple or the third temple.
All right, okay. So, these are the
And then you have the Islamic
eschatology,
okay? And
Islamic eschatology is a response to all
these other eschatologies,
where
they say that when this system is
created, it will be called Dajjal.
Dajjal, the Antichrist, okay?
And when this happens, then Jesus will
return
to defeat the Antichrist.
Okay, that's the mainstream Islamic
eschatology. Then you have the Shia,
okay? The Shia are Remember, are the
Iranians,
where they believe that it's not It will
be the 12th
Imam Mahdi
who will lead
the
followers, okay? The Ummah. Okay, Ummah
just means community of of believers, to
believers,
into victory
against the Antichrist, the Dajjal,
okay?
So, you can see how these eschatologies
are basically lining up together,
right? The Shia are the Iranians. The
Islamic is the entire Arab world, all
right?
Now, there are other two more
eschatologies I I I want to look at. And
again, I know this is a lot. I know this
is too much information, and we'll go
over these eschatologies specifically as
we move along, okay? But I just want to
introduce the different eschatologies.
Another eschatology that's very
important is the Catholic eschatology.
And in the Catholic eschatology, we can
call City of God,
okay? Which is
the church,
which is Jerusalem.
And Saint Augustine
talked about this,
about how the Catholic Church, it is the
millennium. It is the Messianic age
because we represent God, and we bring
peace and prosperity to the world. Now,
what's important about the church is
that it became the dominant power in the
world because Rome fell, okay? So, Roman
Empire collapses,
but this is all part of God's divine
plan because Roman Empire, Rome, was the
city of
earth, okay? Of power, of money, of
wealth.
>> [music]
>> And what matters is Jerusalem, the city
of God, of spirituality,
of um
divinity, okay?
Now, the City of God came to an end
because of the rise of the Protestants
and the Anglo-American empire.
So, for the Catholic Church to achieve
its eschatology and establish again the
City of God. What they need to do is
also see the
American Empire destroyed just like the
Roman Empire.
Okay? So, that is the Catholic
eschatology. The last eschatology
I want to discuss is the Orthodox
eschatology. And what's the Orthodox
eschatology?
The Russians, okay?
This is called the Third Rome prophecy.
Okay? The Third Rome prophecy is
basically that Moscow
will become the Third Rome. Okay, the
first Rome The First Rome was Rome,
second Rome was Constantinople, the
Third Rome will be Moscow.
>> [snorts]
>> And also what's really important to
uh appreciate is that there will be no
Fourth Rome. So, when Moscow becomes the
Third Rome, history ends.
Okay? And peace and prosperity will come
to the world. Okay? So, so what does
this mean? It means that
Russia will well unite the Orthodox
world.
Okay? So, right now the Orthodox world
is split into Eastern Orthodox see
um and Greek Orthodox see, okay?
And something that is very important
that this prophecy says is that the
Russians will defeat Turkia
in a war and then have the Greeks return
to Constantinople, which is modern-day
Istanbul. Okay? That's what the prophecy
says.
And so, you look at all these different
eschatologies, okay? And again, guys,
this is the majority of the world,
right? If you actually look at the
convergence points, you come to some
startling
um conclusions, okay? So, let's let's
look at the convergence.
All right. Where do they converge? Okay?
Well, first of all,
okay? Where they converge is that
the greater
Israel project
will be achieved, okay? Pax Judaica will
be achieved.
It's a one world government, okay? One
world government.
That is one major convergence. If that's
true, then another convergence is
the Al-Aqsa Mosque
will give way to the Third Temple.
All these eschatologies either say this
or indifferent to saying this, okay?
They're not opposed to this. All right?
So, that's that's why I predict the
Third uh the Al-Aqsa Mosque will be
destroyed because they need to build a
Third Temple.
Another thing where which in which um
they converge is the rise of
anti-Semitism.
Why? Because that will force the
diaspora the Jewish diaspora to return
to Israel. This is very important for
this eschatology, okay?
All right?
Another important convergence point is
the war of Gog and Magog.
We don't actually know what this is, but
this war is supposed to be the final war
before the return of God, before the end
of history, before the end of the world,
okay? What this war is, we don't know
yet, but another thing this is that this
war in Iran will lead to the war of Gog
and Magog at some point, okay? What this
war is, we'll discuss at a later time.
Another thing that's very important is
US and China
are not part
of this eschatology.
Okay? This is where everyone agrees.
For whatever reason, the United States
is not going to partake
in future events. Neither will China,
which means that
um something will happen to these two
two countries that will make them not
significant anymore, okay? And the best
prediction for the United States then is
civil war.
Right?
Okay? Civil war.
Okay? And this is where
um
all these eschatologies converge. So, in
other words, this war in Iran is
happening so that these different
eschatological traditions can achieve
um heaven on earth from their
perspective.
All right? So, what does mean So, given
this convergence, we we can actually
predict certain events that will happen
over the next two to four years.
Okay?
Because they all want these things to
happen together. All right? So, let's
look at some quick predictions.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay? First prediction, of course, is
that the US will use ground troops.
Because using ground troops will create
a national draft.
And what does a national draft do? It
creates a civil war.
Right?
A lot of young people are going to
refuse to fight in this war. And this is
this is going to create protests. Then
America will have no choice but to
deploy the National Guard.
And this will create the recipe for a
lot of civil conflict in America, okay?
Another thing that will happen is
because you use ground troops, you will
lose the war and then CENTCOM, which is
the American military in the Middle
East, will then transfer over to Israel.
Okay?
What's happening in this war is that the
economies of the GCC
are being destroyed and that's part of
the plan, okay? Because for Israel to
achieve the greater Israel project, it
needs to absorb the GCC and parts of
Turkia and parts of Egypt, okay? So,
another way of saying this is that the
GCC is basically finished.
The intention is to collapse their
economies and make them irrelevant.
All right?
The third thing we can expect is that
Turkia
will enter this war And Saudi Arabia,
actually, will enter the war.
>> [clears throat]
>> Because you want to use this war to
weaken opposition to these eschatologies
as much as possible, okay? So, Turkia
and Saudi Arabia will enter this war and
they will suffer tremendously because of
their participation.
All right.
>> [clears throat]
>> Um again, the Al-Aqsa Mosque will be
destroyed.
Okay?
And then
you'll have the rise of Persia.
Okay? The rise of Persia. Why is this
important? Because
um you need this Arab world to unite
against Israel for the end of days.
Right? So, you don't mind if actually
Iran wins this war because by winning
this war, Iran will activate its Persian
identity.
>> [snorts]
>> And this is important for eschatology
because in the war of Gog and Magog,
people are interpreting Gog and Magog,
which will march against Israel,
they're interpreting Gog and Magog to be
Persia and Russia.
Okay?
Okay? Together they will march against
Pax Judaica.
Number six is that in Israel, you will
achieve the Pax Judaica
and the greater Israel project.
Okay? So, the greater Israel project and
Pax Judaica are not the same thing,
guys. Greater Israel is is just
basically the territory
that the Israelis believed that God had
promised to ancestor Abraham. Pax
Judaica is a one world government, okay?
Based on AI surveillance and the mark of
the beast.
So, um what will happen is that um
Israel will use this war to expand its
territory
and then what will happen is that
capital, technology
um will then start to flow to Israel in
order to create the great Pax Judaica.
So, think of companies like Nvidia,
Oracle, Microsoft, Google. Well, they'll
probably transfer themselves to Israel
because that is where the power will
rest. Okay?
Um so, Pax Judaica.
Um then you will have
um Russia
winning the war in Ukraine.
Okay?
And then um
return Greeks to Constantinople.
Basically, another way of saying this is
it is possible that
um
the Greeks go to war against Turkia and
then Russia supports the Greeks and
return the Greeks to Istanbul, okay? But
then you're like, "Wait a minute. Turkia
is a NATO member."
Well, we can also expect
destruction of
of
Europe, okay? The end of NATO,
basically.
So,
this war in Ukraine, it's not just about
Russia protecting its borders. This war
in Ukraine is also meant to achieve
Orthodox eschatology, to destroy Europe,
to destroy NATO so that Russia can
achieve the Third Rome prophecy. That
means the destruction of Europe.
So, I will discuss the Russian-Ukraine
war later on as as we go along, okay?
But, what what I'm trying to show you is
that just by, okay?
Analyzing the most extreme eschatologies
of different religious traditions,
you can then
from this analysis pick out points in
which they agree.
Okay? And and at these points, you can
figure out then how they will affect
current geopolitics to make certain
predictions about how the war will
progress, about how the world will
transform itself next 2 to 4 years.
Okay? So, this is called a law of
eschatological convergence. It gives us
tremendous insight into why things are
turning out the way they are, okay?
Because again, I keep on saying this,
but purely from a geopolitical
perspective, purely from a realpolitik
perspective, this war in Iran makes no
sense.
But, if you look at it from an
eschatological perspective,
then it makes perfect sense, okay?
Any questions?
>> [snorts]
>> Yes.
But, I think like if we look
into the war between America and Iran,
um
I think Trump is trying to destroy Iran
as the same way that he destroys
Venezuela, but it fails, which
let Iran to fight back. So, I think this
could also explain in a political way,
but not religious.
Okay.
All right, that's a great point in that,
listen, there's an explanation, which is
that Trump is just stupid. He's
arrogant. They had too much success in
Venezuela. They go into Iran, they think
it's the same thing, and now they're
losing, okay?
And because they're losing, um they are
just panicking, okay? Okay, that's true.
And um
if this explanation is true, then what
will happen? What we can expect to
happen is that Trump declares victory
and goes home.
Okay? That's what what what we can we
can expect.
Um [snorts]
and if if if the US does go home, then
you're right, okay?
So,
we can expect but sorry,
um the question then is what happens
next few months, all right?
What you need to understand is this.
Um war isn't simple.
Once you start a war, you can't end the
war, all right? So, let me explain
really
really quickly why, okay?
So, [snorts]
you have Iran,
and the main
thing the main advantage that Iran has
over the United States is the GCC
cannot defend itself.
Okay? Because it's just a desert. And
Iran, it's a mountain fortress, so it
can shoot rockets, it can shoot drones
at the GCC, and the GCC can't can't
defend itself, okay? Before, they
thought these US bases could defend
against Iran, but now you recognize
these US bases can't defend themselves
either, okay?
All right? So, um the other thing that
Iran did was close off the Strait of
Hormuz.
Okay? They close off the Strait of
Hormuz. And this is important because
the GCC then
um exports
oil to Asia and gets back food, okay?
So, the GCC basically requires the
Strait of Hormuz
uh in order just to survive.
Okay? Now,
let's just say the US don't comes like,
you know what? Screw this. This is a
stupid war. The Middle East is stupid.
We're going to go home, okay? What
happens now? What happens is that Iran
says to GCC, "Hey, man, you attacked us.
You destroyed our infrastructure. You
destroyed our economy. You have to pay
pay pay a pay a compensation, okay?
Right? Also, hey, man, now we control
the Strait of Hormuz, so if you want to
um use Strait of Hormuz, you have to pay
us a toll. You have to pay us a tax.
Right? So, all this money of the GCC
before it's going to the United States
um to fuel the US economy, now where
where does it go? It goes to Iran.
Right? That's a lot of money, man. We're
talking about trillions of trillions of
dollars. And what will Iran use with
this money? It will use its money this
money to repair its economy. So, in 5 10
years,
this is going to be an economic miracle
where now Iran is able to industrialize
really fast.
And as a result, what's going to happen?
What's going to happen is that the
United States leaves the Middle East,
Iran becomes the superpower,
and controls the entire Middle East.
Right? Now, what Now, Israel
has nuclear weapons.
And so, what's going to happen is that
Israel and Iran will sign a peace
treaty.
Okay? But, the United States
won't be involved. The United States
goes home. It doesn't get any money from
the GCC. What's going to happen to the
US economy? It's going to collapse. Why?
Because the entire US economy is based
on the stock market, on finance, on AI,
on investment from the GCC.
Right?
So, the question then is, can Americans
go home? The answer is, no, they can't.
Because if they go home, their economy
is going to collapse, and their people
are going to have a revolution anyway.
So, you're better off sending people to
Iran than have the people in America
cause a revolution.
Right?
Okay?
So, you're right in that it's possible
that Donald Trump made a mistake, but it
doesn't matter if it was intentional or
accidental. You have the same outcome.
And and strangely enough, this strange
this outcome that you have matches that
aligns with these different
eschatologies in the world.
Okay? Does that make sense?
Okay. All right, any more questions?
All right, okay. So, we'll continue this
next week, guys, okay?